t et c'est en direct
allo
bonjour et bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo ensemble nous allons revenir
pendant 45 minutes sur l'actualité et de
la semaine tous les faits qui vous ont
marqué en passant bien sûr en commençant
par la visite en france du colonel
kadhafi les mesures annoncées concernant
le pouvoir d'achat ou encore la
signature du traité européen c'est jean
luc mélenchon qui est notre invité cette
semaine ensemble on va revenir sur tous
ces faits d'actualité et on commence par
un petit portrait de vous dresser par
emilie il frémit alors il était une fois
jean luc mélenchon ça commence à tanger
le 19 août 1951 c'est en effet au maroc
que vous voyez le jour vous devenez
ensuite un enfant du jura les années
passent un peu plus tard vous suivrez
des études de lettres modernes est de
philosophie avant de rejoindre l'unef
puis le courant trotskiste un autre
genre de formation intellectuelle en 76
vous adhérez au parti socialiste de
françois mitterrand votre héros en
politique le maître dont on m'a dit que
vous me supporter toujours pas qu'on
dise du mal encore aujourd'hui en 2007 à
la fin à des années 80 à vous fondez
pour la première fois votre propre
courant ça s'appelle la gauche
socialiste et c'est avec votre copain
julien dray en 2007 un peu la
consécration puisque vous voilà ministre
grâce à lionel jospin ministre en charge
de l'enseignement professionnel alors
après le traumatisme du 21 avril vous
fondez cette fois avec henri emmanuelli
un autre courant nouveau titre le
nouveau monde vous y pour fonder le
libéralisme et notamment celui des
dirigeants européens ce qui explique
qu'en 2005 vous serez l'un des plus
ardents défenseurs du non au référendum
raison pour laquelle vous choisirez
aussi laurent fabius pour porter les
couleurs du ps en 2007 après la victoire
de ségolène royal aux primaires
d'ailleurs vous ne vous résignez pas
aidé r ce n'est pas votre genre et vous
tenté jusqu'au bout de promouvoir une
candidature de la gauche du ps soutenue
par le pc et par les courants anti
libéraux alors c'est vrai que face à cet
itinéraire à cet itinéraire parents de
rebelles un brin gauchistes on en
oublierait presque que vous êtes
également sénateur depuis 1986 alors à
ce sujet j'ai envie de vous poser la
question que tout le monde se pose est
que tout le monde vous pose comment
est-ce que ce tribun un peu wire et
irrévérencieux que vous êtes a réussi à
se couler dans les dorures silencieuse
de la chambre haute
beau paradoxe complémentaire c'est
jamais très favorables à l'institution
que représente le sénat pas tel qu'il
est ni les personnes qui le composent
aujourd'hui mais l'idée de d'un sénat je
suis un républicain comme vous l'avez
dit à ses ardents et dans cette vision
de la république
l'essai n'a pas tellement la patrie
depuis depuis 20 ans
je le respecte je fais mieux de le
supporter et je le respecte je me trouve
à mon aise parce que précisément je ne
suis pas soumis aux aléas de du moment
non c'est un lieu où on peut travailler
et réfléchir avec beaucoup de sérieux
alors comment comment on fait on fait
voilà on s'est trouvé en situation c'est
une affaire ce n'est pas attribuable
qu'à mon talent c'était un truc vert
lesieu circonstances qui ont fait que
j'ai été sénateur de l'essonne c'est un
grand honneur pour moi que de l'être
encore aujourd'hui
ça m'émeut toujours autant d'en parler
allez enfin attaquer ensemble
l'actualité de la semaine et on commence
bien sûr avec le début d'un long trop
long peut-être séjour en france du
colonel kadhafi
lundi limousine blanche motards sirène
et polémique lundi l'arrivée du colonel
kadhafi à paris provoque des remous et
ce au sein même du gouvernement
la secrétaire d'état aux droits de
l'homme rama yade se fâche ce qui
n'empêche pas le guide libyen d'aller
planter sa tente dans les jardins de
l'hôtel marigny souci que le récit de
cette rocambolesque journée de lundi
avec céline bittner c'est en limousine
blanche que le colonel kaddafi pénètre
dans la cour de l'elysée il passe en
revue la garde républicaine qui lui rend
les honneurs
avant d'être accueilli sur le perron par
le président de la république nicolas
sarkozy
l'entretien durera un peu moins d'une
heure à la clé pour la france selon le
président de la république plus d'une
dizaine de milliards d'euros de contrats
un entretien durant lequel nicolas
sarkozy a demandé au colonel kadhafi de
faire des efforts sur les droits de
l'homme mais justifie une nouvelle fois
l'accueil du guide libyen
la défense des droits de l'homme c'est
pas des pétitions de principe entre soi
ce sont des résultats aujourd'hui les
infirmières sont libres le président
kadhafi a tourné le dos à l'armement
nucléaire et au terrorisme
et c'est dans ce cas qui doit être
encouragée pour que la libye revienne
nombre de la communauté internationale
nicolas sarkozy en a également profité
pour renouveler sa confiance aux rama
yade les propos virulents de la
secrétaire d'état au journal le parisien
dans provoqué la polémique jusque dans
les rangs de l'ump
la france ne doit pas recevoir ce baiser
de la mort explique t'elle fait après
midi la secrétaire d'état a tempéré ses
propos et dit ne pas vouloir
démissionner du côté du parti socialiste
on dénonce la cacophonie du gouvernement
et on critique l'accueil réservé au
colonel kadhafi moi je ne suis pas naïf
je comprends le réalisme je condamne
l'hyper réalisme et le cynisme je pense
qu'une politique qui n'a plus aucun
principe d'une mauvaise politique
j'observe que la diplomatie nicolas
sarkozy plus en plus une diplomatie de
complaisance dans laquelle on tolère
tous les nouveaux amis fustige les moins
fréquentables
alors jean luc mélenchon on va voir tout
à l'heure qu'au fil de la semaine la
polémique kadhafi est un peu aller
crescendo
mais au départ en amont sur le principe
est ce si choquant de la part de la
france de vouloir encourager un pays qui
c'est vrai fait des progrès sur le
chemin de la respectabilité
internationale c'est à dire qu'on est
tous un peu partagé entre les gens
raisonnables à jeudi par les gens qui
sont à la posture et qui gesticulent
d'un côté comme de l'autre breton il ya
personnes en france qui soutiennent la
forme de gouvernement que représente le
colonel kadhafi je crois en tout cas pas
moi
et puis l'autre
l'autre aspect c'est que quand on invite
quelqu'un chez soi on évite de l'insulté
je suis pas très raisonnable créée par
les propos notamment des partis
socialistes parce que mon parti a fait
ce qu'il fallait il a rappelé sur tous
les tons à quel point il est attaché aux
droits de l'homme ce dont personne ne
doutait a priori mon frère certains en
fait trop c'est ce que vous voulez dire
bah c'est à dire que je peux je
comprends pas ce que vient de dire par
exemple pierre moscovici dit je
comprends le réalisme pas l'hyper
réalisme alors bon où est le curseur
oui ben voilà on dit qu'on n'est pas
d'accord avec le colonel khadafi on dit
qu'on n'est pas d'accord éventuellement
avec la politique que pratique le pays
avec le colonel kadhafi mais il me
semble que il faut pas non plus tomber
dans la disproportion insulté un invité
de la france toute la semaine en
rajouter le contraire dans le sens comme
bernard kouchner
alors non cela c'est le cochonnet rama
yade c'est le le plus ce sont les deux
figures emblématiques du cynisme
parce que oui les horizons tous les
cynisme à d'une part ils sont deux ils
disent ah bah c'est inadmissible qu'on
ne reçoive le colonel kadhafi c'est un
tyran ceci cela toutes choses qui sont
fondées et puis après 10 baba nous reste
quand même au gouvernement alors il faut
savoir ce qu'ils reprochent au chef de
l'état de faire ils le pratiquent eux au
centuple
c'est à dire le cynisme je pense une
chose j'en dis une deuxième et j'en fais
une troisième donc ces deux là
heureusement ils comptent pour rien donc
ça va ils apprécieront la ville c'est la
part des deux mais franchement je je je
prends à témoin ceux qui m'écoutent
quelle est la conséquence pratique de ce
que dit monsieur kouchner ou madame rama
yade zëro ils peuvent dire ce qu'ils
veulent tous à l'unsa façon de ne plus
valoir le siège éjectable du
gouvernement et à l'autre dont plus
personne n'est surpris de le voir se
comporter d'une manière aussi visa dans
ses principes il vous écoute peut-être
alors autre temps fort de ce lundi
l'interview que s'est offert le premier
ministre a dans le quotidien les échos
l'occasion pour françois fillon de
préciser les grands chantiers
économiques à venir avec un certain
pessimisme croissance revue à 1,9 pour
2007 et incertitude encore plus forte
pour 2008 tout de suite plus de détails
avec sophie sort aussi croissance en
berne semaine sociale agitée
délocalisation des sites de production
de ads sa coexistence avec nicolas
sarkozy dans un entretien au quotidien
économique les échos
le premier ministre n'esquive aucune
réponse droit dans ses bottes il affirme
inutiles les grèves de la sncf et de la
ratp
quoi qu'il en soit toutes les grandes
réformes économiques seront lancés d'ici
à la fin 2008
à commencer par celle des régimes
spéciaux de retraite celle du marché du
travail et la modernisation de
l'économie
françois fillon devrait annoncer 80
propositions pour une révision générale
des politiques publiques
alors donc si vous avez bien lu françois
fillon dans les échos jean luc mélenchon
vous avez compris que la réforme du
marché du travail se fera bien un début
2008 et comme le dit le premier ministre
comme ça tous les grands chantiers
économiques aura été auront été lancés
ils vont vite aujourd'hui dans
l'exécutif oui je crois que ça leur
technique de vouloir asphyxier
l'éventuelle opposition par le nombre
des fronts qu'ils ouvrent alors
évidemment court partout enfin on a au
moins la simplicité de du fil conducteur
c'est une politique libérale très très
dure un bon la france n'avait pas connu
ça les autres pays il avait connu c'est
notre tour donc on va voir comment on va
avoir la capacité de répliquer mais moi
ce qui me choque là aussi c'est le
cynisme là encore une fois en duo fera
tout pour empêcher à des aides
délocaliser sa production enfin se fiche
de nous eads
il faut d'abord réfléchir sur les
raisons pour lesquelles on arrive à
cette absurdité
nous avons fait l'euro pour nous
protéger et on se retrouve maintenant
avoir des entreprises qui fuient la zone
euro pour pouvoir produire
enfin quel est le cas les le il ya bien
quelque chose qui tourne pas rond et
comment monsieur fillon peut-il dire
qu'il va tout faire et en même temps ils
signent le nouveau traité de lisbonne
européen qui lui recommande ce type de
situation confirmant les tendances à
l'européenne mais il faut quand même que
ces gens aient au moins le courage de se
souvenir le matin de ce qu'ils ont dit
la veille à les autres sujets totalement
différente les laisser là dans le cadre
du projet de loi de finances pour 2008
le gouvernement a essayé de s'attaquer à
un privilège qui date de l'ancien régime
celui des bouilleurs de cru depuis
toujours en effet les agriculteurs
peuvent distille de l'alcool sont
s'acquitter de taxes pour l'instant ce
régime d
rogatoire est prolongé jusqu'en 2013
pierre bande joseph s'est rendu dans
leurs chais va bouillir de crue lorsque
michel descend dans sa cave c'est
uniquement pour les invités de marque
depuis 1958 il a hérité de son beau-père
du privilège de pouvoir distiller des
litres d'alcool pur par an 20 bouteilles
de calvados que ce normand garde
précieusement à bancal voir c'est ce que
prouve bien qu'ils ne brûlent pas me +
pense bien qu'il faut mais qui ne vole
pas alors quand on parle à michel de
revenir sur l'exonération de taxes dont
bénéficie sa production
il se fâche une colère teintée d'émotion
où son forum parce que voulait mourir
avec coup droit de vous dire quant à moi
c'est fini
et comment n'y a pas
aura-t-il page à chaque fois un petit
coup les français les origines de l'ain
en fait bon on a peu serré la vis à la
bombe à céret na'vis à l'eau comme ça on
arrive à abaisser encore plus le
français moyen
on les descend plus en plus c'est la
politique du salami une petite tranche
et les ânes qui tranchaient les eaux
mais je sais pas quand le salami vague
fini il va pas rester grand chose dans
l'assiette
le secret de fabrication de la famille
des fûts de chêne baigné de genièvre et
de l'africain comme variétés de pommes
partira avec michel le droit de bouillir
n'est plus transmissible depuis des
années 60
en attendant il garde quelques bonnes
bouteilles pour ses enfants
dans le fond de la cave aller avec ce
grand cru on passe maintenant à la
journée de mardi et la suite du
feuilleton kadhafi
mais avant cela tragique journée mardi
avec ces deux attentats meurtriers à
alger attentat à la voiture piégée il
visait des bureaux des nations unies
ainsi que les sièges de la cour suprême
et de la cour constitutionnelle plus de
30 morts au total beaucoup y voient bien
sûr la signature d'al qaïda condamnation
unanime des mardis de la communauté
internationale et cette minute de
silence dans l'hémicycle du palais
bourbon mardi avant que ne démarre le
débat sur l'europe minutes également
observé mardi au palais du luxembourg
c'est de paris que le colonel kadhafi a
lui aussi dénoncé ces attentats le guide
libyen qui au deuxième jour de son
voyage a continué de susciter la
polémique il faut dire que ce jour là il
était à l'assemblée nationale reçu par
son président bernard accoyer sur fond
de boycotts de toute la gauche et d'une
partie de la droite
le récit avec céline bittner il voulait
à tout prix marquer le coup les
socialistes qui étaient mis ses côtés
c'est contre la venue du colonel kadhafi
à l'assemblée nationale alors que
bernard kouchner pas l'europe
quelques minutes plus tard jean marc
ayrault revient à la charge et dénonce
la terre est réservé au leader libyen on
ne déroule pas le tapis rouge de
l'assemblée nationale à un homme qui n'a
jamais exprimé publiquement le moindre
regret concernant les attentats dans son
régime s'est rendu coupable contre des
ressortissants français et étrangers
la réponse du ministre des affaires
étrangères ne tarde pas tourné vers ses
anciens amis le face à face à des verts
de règlement de comptes en 2003 le
colonel kadhafi dont je ne suis pas à
des acides et a renoncé au terrorisme et
aux armes de destruction massive c'est
bien alors nous encourageons cette
évolution le tapis rouge je ne sais pas
ce que ça veut dire il a visité la
france est en tout cas c'est pas ça qui
va c'est pas ça qui s'est pas la couleur
du tapis qui force des le tapis rouge
était pourtant bien déroulé quand le
colonel kadhafi a fait son entrée à
l'hôtel de lassay en fin de matinée il a
été accueilli par bernard accoyer
les deux hommes s'entretiennent un quart
d'heure avant de participer à une
réception présence d'une trentaine de
députés
et la gauche a décidé de boycotter le
colonel kadhafi prend la parole sur le
darfour le proche-orient et tente même
une petite leçon politique n'avait pas
vraiment une idée claire de la façon
dont l'expérience des congrès populaires
et des comités populaires
il fonctionne en libye comment est-ce
que nous sommes encore au pouvoir 38 ans
plus tard on ne boit pas moi je dis que
je suis encore au pouvoir 38 ans plus
tard justement parce que je ne suis pas
au pouvoir
si j'avais vraiment été au pouvoir je ne
serais pas resté aussi longtemps 38 ans
c'est le peuple libyen qui est au
pouvoir
à la sortie bernard accoyer tente de
calmer le jeu et dit avoir évoqué les
problèmes des droits de l'homme avec le
leader libyen
le président de l'assemblée nationale
veut rassurer sa majorité qu'à la visite
de mouammar kadhafi a semé le trouble
jusque dans les rangs de l'ump
quand on parle d'une situation
catastrophique et qu il ya de petits
progrès il faut les encourager mais
comme il faut les encourager à accomplir
des pas considérables encore et bien
quand la situation sera bonne
only on le recevra à l'assemblée
nationale on n'y est pas encore à
l'extérieur de l'assemblée nationale
quelques personnes ont manifesté contre
la visite du leader libyen elles ont été
très vite délogés par les forces de
police alors kadhafi reçu à l'assemblée
nationale ça c'était quand même un peu
too much
c'est le choix de il ya bien quelqu'un
qui l'a invité la non ne croyez pas
c'est à lui qu'il faut poser la question
je pense qu'il ya une dimension un peu
provocatrice de certains dans cette
affaire cette contente le sénat n'est
pas lancé d'invitation colonel kadhafi
je peux faire je pense que c'est une
chose de dire on le reçoit on n'invite
pas ce qu'il ya dans le concert des pays
civilisés qui s'interdisent les méthodes
telles que le terrorisme et c'en est une
autre
on a rajouté un et de donner
l'impression de une visite attendue et
chérie je trouve que la ccp c'est de la
provocation y compris pour kadhafi ça le
met dans une situation assez pitoyable
parce que il y à l'assemblée mais y'a
personne les gens qui ne sont pas
contents non tout ça est vrai raté cette
visite en france je pour l'instant c'est
plutôt la lure que de que ça personne ne
peut être content ni ceux qui ont envie
d'adresser un signal amical ou peuple
libyen ni ceux qui ont envie de dire en
france non n'accepte pas tout allez on
revient maintenant à l'actualité
parlementaire mardi avec le sénat qui
achevait son marathon budgétaire en
adoptant le projet de loi de finances
pour 2008 un budget marqué par un
déficit de 41,7 milliards d'euros
dorothée thénault les caisses sont vides
cris l'état rigueur cris bruxelles le
budget 2008 fait avec le sénat prévoit
un déficit pour 2008 de 41,7 milliards
d'euros ralentissement de la conjoncture
paquet fiscal de quelque 15 milliards
d'euros
impossible d'équilibrer les comptes
obsession donc renflouer les caisses
pour ce faire une baisse historique du
nombre de fonctionnaires avec le non
remplacement d'un fonctionnaire partant
à la retraite sur 3,23 1900 - en 2008
dont 2200 postes supprimés dans
l'éducation nationale
sans surprise l'enseignement scolaire et
le plus gros poste de dépenses avec 59,3
milliards d'euros la justice aussi est
gâté avec un budget en augmentation de 4
5% et 1600 création d'emplois quant au
ministère de l'écologie et du
développement durable créée en mai 2007
il recevra 10,1 milliards d'euros
l'enseignement supérieur et la recherche
eu un poids lourd de la discussion avec
une enveloppe de 23 3 milliards soit une
hausse de 1 milliards du budget des
universités l'état va dépenser 400 euros
de plus pour chaque étudiant un marathon
sa chef cent trente heures de débat 188
amendement voté un marathon basé sur une
incertitude ce budget est bâti sur une
prévision de croissance de 2,25 pour
cent pour 2008
mais l' ocde vient de revoir ses
prévisions à la baisse 1,9 pour cent
pour la zone euro dimanche le 1er mai
istres a reconnu être inquiet et puis
les parlementaires ont renoncé à
récupérer sur les successions les sommes
versées dans le cadre de l'apa
l'allocation personnalisée d'autonomie
l'amendement avait pourtant été adopté
par le sénat mais il a été rejeté à la
demande du gouvernement en commission
mixte paritaire
il faut dire que la mesure a suscité un
tollé cette semaine à gauche mais aussi
dans le milieu associatif
un million de personnes âgées touchant
france l'a pas le sénat vient d'ailleurs
de constituer une mission d'information
pour réfléchir justement au financement
de la dépendance nicolas sarkozy
s'attaque à la crise du logement le chef
d'état veut doubler le nombre de
bâtiments anciens rénovés chaque année
en commençant par les hlm
l'état va par ailleurs vendre des
terrains pour construire 60 mille
logements nouveaux d'ici 2012 et la
situation des occupants hlm sera
réexaminée tous les trois ans thomas
raguet nicolas sarkozy veut plus de
transparence pour réduire les abus et
rendre au logement social son rôle
d'intégration
désormais la situation de chaque ménage
devra être réexaminée tous les trois ans
pour envisager soit un maintien dans le
logement soit un roe logement dans un
logement plus adapté au sein du parc
social
soit un parcours d'accession à la
propriété cible du président les
bénéficiaires d'un logement social dont
la situation a évolué emploi salaires ou
le plus souvent des personnes âgées
rester seul dans un grand appartement
après le départ de leurs enfants
moi je suis pour qu'on essaye
humainement de régler ces situations qui
sont situations les plus nombreuses il
faut donc arrêter de leur dire site un
logement plus petit avec la nouvelle
location tu paieras plus cher pour le
trois pièces qu'on va te donner que sa
pièce que tu viennes qui dit il faut
être lucide qu'on peut pas proposer des
logements qu'ils soient situés hors des
quartiers qui sont les quartiers où où
les gens ou les genres d'eysines
à cela s'ajoutent les locataires dont
les ressources dépassent le plafond
autorisé après un changement de
situation il représenterait sept pour
cent des occupants actuels
et puis mardi encore une nouvelle
réunion
de la gauche plurielle autour de la
table parti socialiste les verts le pc
mrc de jean pierre chevènement est au
menu de cette deuxième rencontre depuis
la rentrée le pouvoir d'achat mardi nous
étions en effet à la veille de la
présentation en conseil des ministres du
projet de loi du gouvernement sur ce
sujet le reportage de pierre rondeau
afin kadhafi à paris et c'est toute
l'opposition qui retrouve des couleurs à
l'entrée de la deuxième réunion du
comité de liaison de la gauche le voyage
officiel du dictateur libyen a réussi le
tour de force de mettre tout le monde
d'accord qu'on ait des rapports avec
d'état et à métaux huile d vous nous
déroule le tapis rouge alors que cet
homme est un dictateur c'est à 10 ans
quand je ne peux pas oublier que le
régime de kadhafi a été accusée d'actes
terroristes contre un avion français
il y a eu des ressortissants français
qui sont morts
au parti socialiste on parle volontiers
de moments importants mais avec un pc
chaos depuis les présidentielles et un
ps affaibli
pas sûr que la photo de groupe suffisent
à la gauche pour retrouver un second
souffle à l'issue de deux heures de
réunion
la riposte viendra sur le plan du
pouvoir d'achat on peut plafonner à le
montant des loyers bloquer les loyers
pendant un certain temps qu'on peut
limiter le coût d'énergie par
l'isolation des logements qu'on peut
améliorer la qualité des transports en
commun et qu' aucune de ses propositions
que nous portons de sont mis en oeuvre
par le gouvernement nicolas sarkozy
mais le consensus à la vie courte dès la
sortie des divergences ressurgissent
pour les prochaines élections
municipales les verts ne veulent pas
entendre parler d'accord de désistement
des au premier tour au profit du parti
socialiste pas d'accord non plus sur le
traité européen
le comité de liaison de la gauche porte
bien son nom pour l'union on attendra
alors jean-luc mélenchon ça vous fait
plaisir de voir comme ça la gauche
réunis autour d'une même table qui se
parlent et qui s'entend oui parce que là
le commentaire est excessivement dur
d'abord la réunion ait lieu et deuxième
mandat sorti un texte et on a sorti un
texte pas un texte de convenance on a
discuté longuement puisque ça a duré le
double du temps prévu non il n'est pas
intéressant qui sont faits et non via un
texte sur des points oui qu'ils
s'accordent sur la wii mais qu'on
s'accorde sur la critique de la
politique du gouvernement sur les
critiques on adresse sur le soi disant
plan de pouvoir d'achat de du président
sarkozy qu'on s'accorde sur des mesures
a opposés à ce plan ça me paraît être
intéressant toujours pas d'accord ni sur
l'europe ni sur les municipales
notamment entre le ps et le pc qui se
disputent dorénavant et bastion
historique du code et communistes
notamment s'est mis à parler du 11e en
plus - de georges ça pour expliquer
aussi de quelques temps gage entre le
mrc le ps ça va pas très bien c'est un
parti fille ciel tout ça non non pas du
tout mais c'est aussi classique que la
gauche vous avez devant vous quelqu'un
qu'à négocier quatre fois des accords de
municipal donc je ne renie jamais même
ça jamais vu une fois que ce soit passé
je n'ai pas dit que tout allait bien je
dis seulement que ce n'est pas vrai que
cette réunion soit le symptôme du
contraire de ce qu alain ce qu'elle nous
montre elle nous montre une rencontre de
la cohésion
écoutez ça va déjà assez mal pour nous
et pas oublier de nous enfoncer la tête
dans l'eau chaque fois qu on la ressort
donc là c'est un bon point pour nous il
ya des points de tension qui sont
d'ailleurs qui vont donner lieu à des
discussions sans doute de fonds parce
que il est exact il n'est pas possible
d'agresser le parti communiste comme
certains se propose de le faire dans
certaines municipalités on peut pas à la
fois vouloir le parti communiste comme
alliés et ensuite lui disputé par tout
ça ça ça après éminence local il faut
aussi savoir un petit peu
vivre en ce sens dont trois dirigeants à
la tête du ps pour avoir une nouvelle
politique à l'égard du pc par exemple
non mais ça ces discussions de municipal
si j'étais moi même le premier
secrétaire du ps ça serait dur pour moi
comme pour n'importe quel autre 1 avec
les communistes et avec d'autres il y
aura des questions on va voir ce sont
des questions conjoncturel cissé local
sis et des énervements locaux ou bien ce
sont des questions de fond de stratégie
moi je crois que pour l'instant nous en
sommes à des énervements locaux et que
le parti à mettre à bonne entente pour
qu'on obtienne le résultat qu'on vous
obtenir c'est à dire des listes d'union
de la gauche de toute la gauche
partout on peut dans le personnel est
heureux d'être aujourd'hui on va
l'appeler autrement parce que ça sera
pas tout à fait la même chose ça est la
gauche plurielle au moins j'ai lu
beaucoup de temps que ça m'amuse
beaucoup
aujourd'hui c'est alors si vous
interrogez jean luc mélenchon il n'y a
pas de limite à gauche moi je suis pour
que tout le monde soit dans attendait
d'abord qu'on fasse la liste de ce côté
là ça veut dire non seulement les
communistes les verts qui sont nos
partenaires naturels
le mdc les radicaux mais aussi la liste
aussi les altermondialiste josé bové
avait aussi arlette laguiller bien sûr
alors les premières fois que j'ai dit ça
au moins que son souvenir au congrès du
membre 10 pauvre mélenchon l'union de la
gauche sans exclusive mais où va-t-il
on me disait mais tu n'imagines pas
arlette laguiller non pendant que tu y
es à l'époque on trouvait ça drôle de
m'interpeller sur arlette laguiller
or aujourd'hui qui sont parmi les autres
gauche et l'extrême gauche qui sont les
premiers à dire ah bah écoute et on est
prêt à discuter c'est justement avec
laguiller dont bruit c'est une affaire
de volonté de l'autre côté je ne veux
pas me esquivé la question vous m'avez
posée moi je réponds très clairement que
nous ne devons pas faire d'alliance
ailleurs qu'à gauche
voilà pourquoi se ferment au centre
c'est la position avec mélenchon oui
comme quelqu'un qui a participé avec
beaucoup de difficulté à l'extraction
des centristes délices de la et ses
filles au dans les années la fin des
années 70 n'est ce pas ça me donne
beaucoup de mal de les faire partir de
là donc c'est pas pour les y remettre
avec la confusion politique que ça
implique de mélanger des gens de droite
les plus ciblés sont locaux devront
attendre on avance et on regarde du côté
de mercredi où il est encore question du
pouvoir d'achat
mercredi en effet le gouvernement a
bouleversé son agenda pour adopter en
conseil des ministres le fameux projet
de loi en faveur du pouvoir d'achat
il sera examiné dès mardi prochain à
l'assemblée nationale il mais vous le
savez en musique les mesures annoncées
par nicolas sarkozy lors de son
intervention télévisée du 29 novembre
dernier paiement des rtt déblocage de
l'epargne salariale encore mesure pour
les loyers tout de suite le détail de ce
texte
regardez combien première tétée non
prise combien pour la mesure phare de
travailler plus pour gagner plus le
projet de loi sur le pouvoir d'achat
prévoit que les heures de rtt rachetées
seront majorées d'environ 10%
et pour inciter les employeurs à mettre
en place ce dispositif les dix premiers
jours rachetées seront exonérées de
cotisations patronales
si cela ne suffit pas xavier bertrand le
ministre du travail a annoncé que les
salariés pourront invoquer la loi en cas
de refus de leur direction de racheter
les rtt non prise dans son panier
gouvernement a également prévu un
déblocage anticipé de la participation
résultats de l'entreprise
ce déblocage sera possible du 1er
janvier au 30 juin 2008
dans la limite de 10 mille euros dans
les entreprises de moins de 50 salariés
où la participation n'est pas
obligatoire une prime de 1000 euros
pourrait être versé sans payer de
charges sociales
enfin dans le domaine du logement
l'augmentation des loyers sera calquée
sur celle de l'inflation
il prendra plus en compte les prêts à la
construction une façon de limiter la
hausse des loyers au 1er janvier
cette première salve de mesures
réussira-t-elle à répondre aux
inquiétudes des français sur le pouvoir
d'achat
pas forcément sûr de son coup le
gouvernement prévoit de revenir à la
charge
un rapport sur le développement du
secteur low cost et du hard discount
vient de lui être remis après le
travailler plus pour gagner plus nicolas
sarkozy paraît donc maintenant sur le
acheter plus en payant moins marcher un
rythme et un chat on ne pourra pas dire
que le gouvernement ne se préoccupe pas
du pouvoir d'achat des français on peut
le dire il ya eu
le paquet fiscal aujourd'hui il ya
encore un nouveau texte de loi belle
réactivité pourrait-on dire non c'est
une triste plaisanterie le gouvernement
se préoccupe des sondages à propos des
de ce que ressentent les français sur
leur pouvoir d'achat à savoir qu'ils
diminuent vous allez le faire y arrête
là du tout sur des mesures concrètes qui
compte que l'on peut résumer de la
manière suivante le président sarkozy
dit aux gens que vous avez des économies
et ben vous pouvez les dépenses et voilà
c'est comme ça qu'il veut faire
progresser le pouvoir d'achat je
n'exagère pas se faire payer les heures
de rtt sont des heures qu'on a travaillé
qui donne droit à des heures de congé
donc les gens ils ont fait c'est leur
argent c'est leurs vacances qu'est ce
qui leur donne monsieur sarkozy ce qui
est déjà eu quand il dit les fonds qui
sont mieux bloquer en participation
c'est l'argent de qui ça c'est l'argent
de qui c'est pas celui du patron c'est
pas celui du gouvernement
c'est l'argent du travail a été
débloquée donc saisi la prochaine fois
que vous irez voir votre patron eh ben
il vous dira écoutez je vous autorise à
prendre l'argent de nos économies voilà
ça sera ça votre augmentation pour ce
mois ci vous diriez écoutez monsieur
vous moquez de moi mais c'est ce que
vient de faire monsieur sarkozy se moque
du monde
c'était la lecture par jean luc
mélenchon du projet doit discuter la
semaine prochaine à l'assemblée alors
autre grand chantier de l'exécutif la
réforme de l'état
ce mercredi première grande réunion
autour de nicolas sarkozy du conseil de
modernisation des politiques publiques à
la sortie 97 mesures proposées parmi
lesquels la délivrance des documents
administratifs transférés à des
préfectures et sous préfectures aux
mairies ou encore la déjudiciarisation
du divorce
une réunion qui était aussi l'occasion
pour le chef de l'état de redire aux
fonctionnaires qui ne fera pas sans eux
la réforme en l'écoutent la réforme de
l'état ne se fera pas contre les
fonctionnaires
j'ai fixé à nantes une grande ambition
pour la fonction publique je constate
que loin des stéréotypes et correspond
aux attentes des fonctionnaires je veux
dire aux fonctionnaires qu'ils peuvent
avoir confiance dans la réforme de
l'état
ils sont les grands bénéficiaires de
cette réforme ils seront moins nombreux
mieux rémunérer leurs conditions de
travail seront améliorées et leurs
perspectives de carrière plus riches et
mercredi on parle aussi europe puisque
on est à la veille du sommet de lisbonne
l'occasion pour les élus français qui
continue de réclamer une ratification du
traité par
faire un dom de tenter un ultime baroud
d'honneur au palais bourbon
vous allez reconnaître sans doute sur
ces images marie george buffet et jean
luc mélenchon
ils sont au total 80 parlementaires
avoir signé un appel pour refuser cette
ratification par voie parlementaire
autres baroud d'honneur ce même jour
mais cette fois ci au parlement européen
des euro députés d'extrême gauche et
d'extreme droite également partisan d'un
référendum ont perturbé la séance où les
voiliers aux cris de référendum
référendum et en arborant des tee-shirts
noirs et des pancartes de circonstance
alors jean-luc mélenchon vous avez eu
l'occasion cette semaine de dire à
l'assemblée que l'objectif du
gouvernement de faire ratifier par le
parlement début février le traité
européen cela relevait du hold up vous
n'exagérez pas un peu quand il faut
trouver une expression pour retenir
votre attention alors je vois que j'ai
réussi grave
ce qui est important c'est d'abord qu'on
ne dise pas que c'est un baroud
d'honneur parce que nous ne sommes pas
une assemblée de manants qui vient à
casquette à la main demandé à son
seigneur de bien vouloir prendre leur
avis nous avons des droits
je dois dire au président sarkozy quoi
qu'il ait dit dans sa campagne je lui en
donne acte que entre deux élections
présidentielles dans la station est un
peu désespéré pas gain de cause
attendez si vous me laissez l'expliquez
vous verrez pourquoi je veux obtenir
gain de cause
mais entre les deux la république
continue et en particulier pour que le
traité soit ratifié il faut d'abord
changer la constitution française c'est
ce qui est prévu le 4 février les voilà
les parlements qu'on est sans merci de
le préciser car les gens ne comprennent
pas qu'il y à deux votes et à ce premier
vote il faut que le président sarkozy
est une majorité des trois cinquièmes et
nous nous avons besoin des deux
cinquièmes pour bloquer si nous bloquons
le président et ça fait trop obligé de
demander je vais le dire à l'instant
mais si nous bloquons la réforme de la
constitution français le président est
obligé de faire le référendum par
conséquent la question se joue à savoir
si oui ou non il a les trois cinquièmes
si oui ou non nous avons les deux
cinquièmes à leur première réponse il
n'a pas et 3 5e
il lui manque en principe 15
parlementaires souverainiste
deuxième réponse nous n'avons pas les
deux cinquièmes il nous manque lui voir
si toute la gauche votent pour bloquer
la réforme de la constitution censée
très courtisé dans l'est
ça veut dire que ça va être très serré
et j'ajoute que comme c'est sur les
suffrages exprimés ça va se compter sur
ceux qui sont présents dans la salle ça
veut dire que ceux qui tout d'un coup
sont pris d'un besoin urgent en moins de
voter il va bien falloir qu'il soit
quand même dans la salle ce qu'avait
prévu de rester à la maison en disant
comme s'agit slip a pas vu pas pris
il faut pas qu'ils comptent que je ne
leur met pas le projecteur sur la figure
parce que chacun est au pied du mur et
assume sa responsabilité moi j'assume la
mienne
donc tous ceux qui sont là devront en
faire autant nous sommes les
représentants du peuple pas les
propriétaires du peuple mais justement
comment vous expliquez que après cet
fortement mobilisés pendant le
référendum en 2005 l'opinion publique
aujourd'hui se désintéresse complètement
de ce traité on peut peut-être risqué à
mes jeux je veux pas être du tout gênant
ne dérangeait personne peut-être qu'on
peut suggérer que les médias n'aient pas
n'être pas beaucoup mais je sais bien
qu'on ne doit pas les critiques et donc
je retire tout de suite passé pédagogie
sur ces questions a indiqué hier soir
nous avons vu sur le service public
c'est à dire france 2 une présentation
du du du traité pour la première fois on
évoquait le fait que des gens voulaient
un référendum mais à aucun moment on a
dit sur aucune chaîne que ça se jouer à
versailles 2/5 3,5 à vous je reconnais
que c'est compliqué vous voyez le temps
qu'il me faut pour l'expliquer qui sait
mieux le faire que vous comme vous
voulez expliquer le plan de pouvoir
d'achat du gouvernement vous prenez le
temps nous et vous prenez point numéro
un point numéro 2 point numéro 3 ya pas
meilleur pédagogue que les médias donc
beaucoup de nos compatriotes comprennent
rien tout ça et il pense par exemple que
des gens comme moi qui demande un
référendum sont des gens qu'il faut une
pétition comme ça pour le principe un
baroud d'honneur comme il a été dit sans
comprendre que la possibilité existe
réel donc l'elysée on a compris on va
continuer sur cette actualité
on va continuer jean luc mélenchon sur
cette actualité européenne puisque c'est
jeudi que le traité a officiellement été
signée par les 25 pays membres de
l'union européenne
jeudi effectivement solennité et
magnificence pour la signature du traité
de lisbonne par les 27 dirigeants
européens
c'en est donc fini pour la constitution
place au traité simplifié ou mini traité
comme certains le nomment pour
l'occasion chaque dirigeant s'est vu
remettre un stylo en argent personnalisé
cérémonie dans le très beau cloître du
monastère des jeronimos pour la france
en plus de nicolas sarkozy françois
fillon et bernard kouchner était du
voyage jean luc mélenchon c'est un jour
de victoire et de satisfaction
personnelle pour nicolas sarkozy ce que
vous pensez qu'il se dit que c'est un
peu grâce à lui que l'europe repas
aujourd'hui je sais pas si tu penses
mais il a réussi un coup par exemple
vous faire avaler l'expression traité
simplifié ce traité est plus long il
comporte trois cent cinquante six
articles sont des amendements d'autres
textes il ya 287 pages 65 déclaration 12
protocole et vous vous répétez en
cadence le traité simplifié alors qu'il
est plus long et plus compliqué que le
précédent il n'y a qu'une chose qui a
été retiré les les aspects que font
plaisir aux nationalistes alors on a dit
on enlève le drapeau on enlève le nom du
président de la commission mais vous
avez des talents derrière nicolas
sarkozy semblé parier avec vous vous
voyez bien giscard d'estaing a dit c'est
une des arrangements cosmétiques
donc on a dit il ya plus le drapeau mais
derrière le président sarkozy a perdu
que c'est une blague c'est le même texte
la dernière fois en plomb en plus mal
écrits en plus difficiles à croquer les
médias l'at-elle mini-traité hockey que
tout le monde l'appelle limite vous êtes
d'abord et manque on peut pas appeler
mini-traité un texte plus long que le
précédent mais à ce point là et bien là
ouais l'actualité maintenant des
universités avec 730 millions d'euros
pour la réussite à l'université valérie
pécresse a lancé jeudi son plan pour
lutter contre l'échec à l'université
chaque année en effet 50% des étudiants
échouent en première année alors la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
propose une refonte complète du contenu
de la licence une meilleure orientation
et un accompagnement personnel renforcé
pierre bande joseph un david welch
david a quitté la fac pour les fourneaux
après deux ans d'études en mathématiques
il rate son deuil et décide de changer
de branche
aujourd'hui cet apprenti cuisinier garde
un mauvais souvenir de son passage à la
faculté à ce qu'il me manquait vraiment
pour avoir mon diplôme disons c'était un
encadrement et un encadrement un peu
particulier une préparation réel à ce
qui nous attendait en partiel et être
sûr des débouchés qui arriveront
justement derrière qui faisait preuve si
david a aujourd'hui une formation qui
lui convient
un étudiant sur deux loupes sa première
année de fac pour lutter contre ce
gâchis valérie pécresse a décidé
d'augmenter de 5 heures les cours et de
mettre en place un suivi individualisé
de chaque élève
ça suppose un professeur référent auquel
l'étudiant pourra s'adresser si jamais
il est en difficulté et ça suppose un
rendez vous à la fin du premier semestre
universitaire pour vérifier si
l'étudiant n'est pas en difficulté s'il
n'a pas besoin de tutorat s'il n'a pas
besoin éventuellement d'une
réorientation très rapide pour éviter
que la licence ne soit une voie de
garage 730 millions d'euros seront
investis d'ici cinq ans dans la filière
des mesures plutôt bien accueilli mais
certains syndicats étudiants regrette
déjà qu'aucun poste d'enseignant ne soit
créée et puis jeudi le sénat a commencé
l'examen du projet de loi luc chatel sur
la consommation ouverture des magasins
le dimanche
gratuité du temps d'attenté sur les
hotlines encore engagement limité auprès
des opérateurs de téléphonie mobile
voici les principales mesures de ce
texte les explications de fabrice qu'une
et le projet de loi de luc chatel du
bricolage c'est du moins l'avis de
l'opposition au sénat qui dénoncent un
manque d'ambition du texte ce texte
intermédiaire relève pour le moins d'une
politique de communication plus que
d'une politique de la consommation qui
aurait mérité une véritable loi
d'orientation
comme l'a souligné notre collègue du
show ce projet de loi vise à développer
la concurrence dans trois domaines et
ainsi faire baisser les prix
le secrétaire d'état est venu rappeler
qu'il n'était qu'une étape dans la
stratégie globale du gouvernement en
faveur du pouvoir d'achat
c'est un texte qui va traiter des
questions de la vie quotidienne et
concerne un tiers du budget des ménages
français sont les dépenses de la
consommation courante et ça va permettre
en remettant de la transparence et la
concurrence de rendre coup du pouvoir
d'achat aux français
principaux ajouts proposés au sénat le
renforcement des droits des
consommateurs devant les tribunaux
d'instance ou encore l'assouplissement
des contrats avec les opérateurs de
téléphonie mobile chez limitée
effectivement les contrats à 24 mois
parce que je pense qu'il faut surtout
pas aller plus loin mais en plus au
niveau des pénalités
j'ai je suis descendu un quart des
pénalités de ce qui reste à courir ce
qui fera beaucoup moins cher pour le
consommateur s'il veut vraiment sortir
avant les 24 mois un amendement de
dernière minute a volé la vedette aux
propositions du rapporteur
il concerne l'ouverture des magasins
d'ameublement le dimanche
les syndicats ont d'ores et déjà annoncé
qu'ils comptaient s'opposer à une telle
mesure
en l'absence de concertation et puis
jeudi lors des questions d'actualité au
sénat rama yade a dû répondre à une
question du groupe socialiste sur la
visite en france du colonel kadhafi
lundi vous vous en souvenez la
secrétaire d'état aux droits de l'homme
s'était montré très critique sur ce
séjour
eh bien je dis elle a dû avaler son
chapeau en l'écoutant la visite en
france du président kadhafi reçoit je le
répète le soutien de l'ensemble du
gouvernement
la libye à réintégrer la communauté
internationale depuis 2003 elle a
relancé au nucléaire militaire
ainsi qu au terrorisme cela a été dit et
sera redit autant que nécessaire bien
sûr on pouvait appréhender cette visite
après les déclarations du colonel depuis
lisbonne et la coïncidence de sa venue
avec la journée des droits de l'homme
mais depuis l'arrivée de votre hôte sur
le sol français
le président de la république s'est
attaché avec constance et réussit à
obtenir du chef d'état libyen des
garanties dans ce domaine jean luc
mélenchon est ce que ça veut dire que
dans ce il n'a y avait un remaniement
dans les semaines qui viennent il n'y
aura sans doute plus de secrétariat
d'état aux droits de l'homme
je sais pas mais là c'était une scène
assez pénible à vivre moi je
me trouver enfin en face de madame
marianne bon clairement elle a mangé son
chapeau
je pense que l'exercice a été voulu par
par le gouvernement le chef du
gouvernement le président de la fbc
c'était très pénible à voir ces deux
femmes lisant un papier qui dit le
contraire de ce qu'elle a dit la veille
et qui a l'air d'en souffrir
mais après elle a aussi un elle peut
recevoir des instructions de sa
conscience et de son miroir elle a dû
démissionner ou vos si elle pense
vraiment ce qu'elle a dit cela n'a pas
de sens et gouvernement ferme sa gueule
non oui parce qu'on doit être d'accord
avec le gouvernement dans lequel on aime
et on peut pas comme c'est son propre
domaine accepté de faire le contraire de
ce qu'on croit juste non enfin une sorte
vous ne croyez pas allez on termine
maintenant la semaine avec vendredi et
on parle à nouveau europe en fin de
semaine puisque les 27 dirigeants réunis
la veille à lisbonne pour signer le
traité simplifié son vendredi à
bruxelles un nouveau sommet pour évoquer
les grands chantiers à venir de l'union
le kosovo la fin de la présidence
portugaise ou encore à la présidence
française ce sera vous savez en juillet
prochain
ge avec mélenchon on le sert cette
présidence française nicolas sarkozy
veut en faire un test un pour démontrer
dit il définitivement le retour de la
france en europe qu'est ce que vous
dites au chef de l'état en la matière
c'est celle de la république française
on qu'on lui dit bonne chance parce
qu'on est les bons citoyens mais c'est
lamentable
il a le soi-disant traité simplifié je
vois vous obstinez appeler ça simplifie
alors qu'il est plus compliqué que le
précédent lui a fait il a tout cédé il
ya tout céder il avait dit vous allez
voir ce que vous allez voir la bce
rien du tout le tarif extérieur rien du
tout l'harmonisation sociale et fiscale
dont on a un besoin vital pour essayer
de rétablir un peu l'équilibré éviter
que d'un ping sociale favorise les pays
qui nous
nous dépouille qu'est ce qu'il a obtenu
à rien c'est toujours interdite dans le
nouveau traité par conséquent pendant sa
présidence je suppose que il fera aussi
des gesticulations cosmétiques je le
crains qu'est ce qu'il lui reste à faire
après avoir signé sa finalement votre
meilleur allié saint aignan open c'est
gordon brown
parce qu'il a vraiment traiter des pieds
traîné des pieds pendant pour aller
dormir
ce n'est pas du thé à lisbonne dénonce
pas du tout monsieur gordon brown est
d'abord un blairiste impénitent et je ne
suis pas de cette opinion et
deuxièmement messieurs gordon brown a
des arguments nationalistes n'est pas
mon cas moi je suis un fédéraliste
européen
je déplore le nouveau traité notamment
parce qu'il ne contient aucun progrès de
démocratie le parlement européen
toujours aussi impuissant et les
parlements nationaux toujours autant
jacques dans mot pour vous compreniez
que ce n'est pas une marotte de ma part
80% des lois qui s'appliquent thani à
vous à moi viennent sont des
transpositions de directives européennes
ont quand même si vous êtes un peuple
libre
vous avez le droit de vous intéresser
aux conditions dans lesquelles se
décident des décisions qui s'appliquent
à vous allez comme toujours on finit
cette émission avec l'agent dale est
temps fort de la semaine à venir et on
commence par l'assemblée nationale nous
en avons parlé
mardi ce sera à l'examen du projet de
loi en faveur du pouvoir d'achat
o senhor lundi et mardi c'est l'examen
du projet de loi de finances
rectificative pour 2007
et puis mercredi c'est la réforme du
code du travail qui vient devant les
sénateurs à l'elysée mercredi à emilie
la conférence avec les partenaires
sociaux pour fixer l'agenda social 2008
et jeudi la visite de nicolas sarkozy au
vatican reste à remercier jean luc
mélenchon d'avoir répondu à nos
questions merci beaucoup et on se
retrouve bien sûr avec perrine la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
parlement hebdo le dernier de l'année
2007 à la semaine prochaine merci à
bientôt
non
et